we were I mean literally getting
threatened to be fired every week when
we would come back the events The Rock
leaves the nation I become Triple H
leave DX we battle over the WWE
Championship like our careers sort of in
a way
marry each other and are intertwined
with each other taker's ear was like
hanging we had a plastic surgeon gonna
meet him in the states and I stood for
the longest time on a seat behind him
putting pressure wow on his head in his
ear because once you get up at pressure
right yeah and leave like a stuck pig
Randy Orton and Dave Batista and then we
put him with us and the whole goal of
that group was to get them both to be
Mega Stars Logan Paul who you guys have
signed up right yeah how you feel about
it you don't do what he's done at
WrestleMania without a lot of hard work
and a lot of effort
foreign
Bible stories today joining us is one of
the greatest WWE legends of all time it
is the one the only is Triple H I am
honored
that was very professional because like
meeting you beforehand I thought wow
this can be very unprofessional and then
I'll tell you we're actually like you
deliver that like you were approach I
just want the producer to note that did
you hear that that's an icons validation
yeah thank you if that could be noted
um
yeah
like London these yeah are you trying
are you going to try and bond over that
the fact that you're both sort of West
Ham fans you're going to use this we
don't need to try it when you're a
hammer you're going to use it it's all
good leave me out you know like I've
been coming here for 30 years so to me
this is It's funny people make such a
big deal sometimes about traveling over
the UK or something like so it's like
going to La it's true yeah you know
you're just crazy to hop on a plane come
here I love it here um
been coming here for years been a part
of this culture here our fan base is so
big here it's awesome yeah and you're in
the UK for clash at the castle this
Saturday in Cardiff Cardiff yeah how's
that all shaping up it's amazing
um you know first of all it's the first
large-scale like premium live event or
pay-per-view that we've uh done here in
30 years so
um you know and we're here all the time
we tour here a lot but this is the first
time for us coming back here with a
stadium show in a massive way like this
um in 30 years so uh it's gonna be crazy
you know I can't wait to get the card if
everybody's been telling us this the
whole city has taken over like you can't
walk two feet without seeing something
about the show or hearing people talk
about it uh we'll probably have the 60
000 Plus in that Stadium yeah it's
packed you can't get a hotel room
passionate as well I mean you can get a
hotel room I heard you talk about it
earlier I've got a friend in a really
high places that was an amazing moment
beforehand obviously we were having a
having a conversation off uh off screen
and and you were in the room and Steve I
was acting like he could hook me up with
a ticket
delusions are Grandeur who do you think
you are if anyone needs anything WWE
related he's the man to talk to in this
room
I'm getting some stuff from him later
should we start with some quick fire
let's go for the quick fire quick fire
um
first of all
pretty simple one I don't even know why
we're starting with it to be honest with
you but you get the cup what is your
name
Triple H there you go where you from
Triple H
yeah what should we talk in reality
based or character wise because reality
based I live in Greenwich Connecticut
wise I live in Greenwich Connecticut
depends on which one you want yeah
what's your occupation hmm that's a
tough one
um do a little bit of everything for WWE
you know it if you want the exact title
I'm the chief content officer for WWE I
I oversee everything that has to do with
uh creative of everything we do from top
to bottom
um
run our talent run our talent
development our recruiting process the
the sort of the life cycle of the talent
from the moment we identify them
in college or wherever they're going to
start from all the way through to the
end of their careers to the Hall of Fame
to Beyond from college I never knew that
that's how early these guys this in in
the UK in the UK in football that's my
Sport and same as NFL in anything really
scouting yeah um I didn't know where do
you go to scout well so it's you know
the it's a different environment than
than what you have here like UK for for
football you guys are
um in some manner you're finding kids
that have a skill set for the game right
and then sort of paying them in essence
to join a club that's affiliated with a
uh
yeah and and sort of following that up
the line and so you've worked with these
guys since you know very very 12 some
eight years I was gonna say eight years
old whatever and and work to them along
the way a little bit different for us
um
it's funny we do have some talent that
started that came from the UK that have
said to me over the years like I never
understood why you guys started
wrestling so late in the states it was
because we have labor laws
that says you can't work and be paid as
a kid uh for somebody so um
yeah
yeah but um
for us in in the U.S it it really now
stems from college are you familiar with
what nil is no so in in in Collegiate
Athletics prior to recently
um NCAA rules you cannot be paid for
anything so if if we were talking
um I'll give you the example of this
Gable steveson do you know what that is
so Gable was uh um just in in may just
graduated from college two-time NCAA
Champion for wrestling
um and then went to the Olympics for the
United States won a gold medal
um an Olympic in the Olympics for
wrestling
um is signed with us now I've known
Gable probably since he was a sophomore
in college I think
um
we had to be extremely careful with
things like even if we wanted to give
him tickets for he and his family to
come to a show because that would be
against NCAA rules he could be
disqualified from Collegiate Athletics
for sort of being paid in some manner
even though we're an entertainment
company very very very tough so it's
always tough for us so Collegiate
Athletics were out for us we had a
recruit in a much different way
um you come in a year and two years ago
uh they changed the rules for what's
called nil name image likeness that
college athletes can use their name and
image and likeness to create a business
for themselves so to speak so they can
be paid for those things they can do
endorsements they can do all these other
things it opened up a world for us
we don't see it as you know paying
somebody a small amount of money to say
hey I watched WWE and isn't that great
um for us it's a recruiting tool for us
it's long-term recruiting so
we look at Collegiate athletes in almost
any sport and we try to work with them
on what WWE is what we are as an
entertainment property but what we are
also behind the scenes some of those
will offer deals to under the nil
program where we'll pay them a sum of
money they will be WWE athletes we help
them build their brand we help them with
media training we help them with life
skills of like finances and and anything
that WWE does that they can have access
to they can come to our performance
center they can do all those things
meanwhile they're out there for us
um sort of talking about WWE to every
sporting event they go to athletes
around the country they're talking about
you know WWE and for most of them
when they graduate from college WWE is
the opportunity that they are looking at
to become a WWE Superstar
for ones that don't that promotion the
entire time is phenomenal for us to talk
about what benefits also and it benefits
them greatly they come out way better
than they went in
um for those that are a part of that
program though when they leave College
athletics so if they're just a shade too
small or whatever that is for the NFL or
not fast enough or anything like that or
you know I use this example all the time
they might be a college Hammer thrower
there's not a lot of calling for Hammer
throwers once you graduate college right
it's either try to go to the Olympics or
get a job coaching or figure out your
career from there this is a way for them
to stay high level Athletics long in
their you know in into their careers and
all of that so
um it's a pathway to WWE that didn't
exist before and it's opened up
Floodgate for us of people now
coming to us rushing towards us looking
for that opportunity whereas before we
kind of had to go select and find them
and say have you ever thought about
becoming a WWE Superstar so difficult
was ever was there a moment for you when
you were young like was there a maybe
that that sort of wrestler that you fell
in love with that made you love the
sport was there an iconic so I fell in
love with the business and I tell the
story a lot and so when I was like five
or six years old I remember sitting in a
in a our living room with my dad
football helmet on American football
helmet on little plastic football was
playing whatever and my dad turned on
wrestling and how long ago was he went
over and turned the channel on the TV
put wrestling on it was Chief J
Strongbow and I remember sitting down on
his lap and just being fascinated by it
like and to me it was the greatest thing
after that I was hooked for me growing
up Ric Flair was sort of the man and the
be-all end-all of yeah exactly wow
but uh to this day and um but sort of
that was my impetus for it and and kind
of it was what I grew up wanting to do
but had no idea how to get into it I
started training at 14 in the gym
because I wanted to be at the WWE
Superstar and I wanted to get big enough
to be a WWE Superstar still having no
idea how to get there and then through a
bunch of unique circumstances as I would
get in my early 20s I would find
somebody that would turn me on to a name
that would help me you know through much
uh bugging yeah they want to give me the
name but I eventually got it and you
know was lucky enough to to get into it
find somebody to train me be good at it
and end up with a career that you've
solved that problem the problem that you
face you've helped to solve because now
at least there is a pathway it is
exactly what I was setting out to try to
do was create that pathway and now we're
in the process of for the last 10 years
or so we've created that recruiting you
know effort also started a brand called
NXT NXT Academy yeah NXT for us is is
that Academy model or that sort of
Collegiate Athletics for us so if Raw
and SmackDown are the NFL for football
for American football NXT is Collegiate
Athletics and we had a small brand here
called NXT UK
um
we were headed down this road prior to
the pandemic pandemic kind of like put a
halt on it but we've just shut that
brand down because we're going to
relaunch it in 23 as NXT Europe and try
to blow it out bigger they have an age
limit yeah
that is a nice towel it's very into
power we spill our water yeah
but the best part is you just wring it
out put it right back
um
you know the in the intent will be to
take NXT Europe and and bring that
around the world so NXT Europe and I'll
I'll just throw names out NXT Australia
NXT South Africa
um South America Mexico right like all
those things and eventually build that
into a global system that will uh lead
to almost a World Cup scenario so the
World Cup finals for NXT will one year
be in London the next year maybe Mexico
City the year after that the sick idea
I'm sorry I believe yeah unbelievable
idea you got to think about it and all
the while really what you're doing is
you're building this you're you're
building a fan base for college football
While You're Building stars for the
major leagues which is Raw SmackDown
WrestleMania right and those markets
feed up and while like in India right
now we are the second biggest sport in
India outside of cricket which is like a
religion team yeah right so it's massive
already but imagine that scale when we
have a brand on the ground of Native
Indian people having their own brand and
then one of them
I'm just saying just one uh branches out
from there goes to Raw goes to SmackDown
headlines WrestleMania it's game
changing yeah absolutely absolutely you
mentioned um Ric Flair I wanted to ask a
questionnaire and I was interesting to
oh ask me when I can tell about them
more of
if you had a Mount Rushmore we call it
we always say who would you pick in your
five or side team of the Legends if you
had a Mount Rushmore of Legends so it's
hard for me to say because you know I
feel like when people give because
that's a such a frequently Asked
question like well who's on your Mount
Rushmore
kinds of how you look at it you know if
you go back uh
40 50 years ago right his name's like
Bruno San Martino Buddy Rogers that
without those people yeah the Hulk
Hogans the Randy Savages the Ricky
steamboats the the Ric flairs they don't
exist right and then if you go past that
into you know this next generation of
stars which you could argue are are
bigger than anything that there's ever
been of the rocks and the Austins and
The Undertakers Shawn Michaels right
like those level of people
um that's a whole different level of
conversation but to say you can only put
four people of all those it's it's sort
of kind of unfair and then when you get
to even that point you say like okay
well how do you
say Mount Rushmore of this industry
without putting vents on it because
without Vince taking what was a regional
promotion and stuff that was happening
for the most part you know people will
go back to the the 30s and the 40s and
say well wrestling was happening in in
giant Arenas and stadiums and it's
totally different right and it went
through his period of time where it was
in like bars and you know very very
small
um
you know taking it out of that and
turning it into a global sensation right
where there's this one brand and and we
can go anyplace in the world and put 60
000 people into a stadium
um and sell it out and and have millions
of people watching around the world it's
a different conversation how could you
have that conversation without putting
him in on that Mount Rushmore as well
you know Mount Rushmore and I didn't
even I didn't even mention like Andre
the Giant like when you talk about that
you talk about somebody that's almost
mythical yeah qualities of who he was a
real human being Andre the Giant but
then almost like mythical quality of
like maybe one of the first sort of like
global
three Superstars like everybody on this
planet knew who Andre the Giant was and
especially in that moment in time so
it's really hard to pick the tough one
is it when you first started out did you
have some explicit goals that you were
hoping to achieve did you have something
in mind that you were hoping to achieve
it's a funny thing like
I start out wanting to be really good at
this so my goal was to be a really
good well-rounded polished performer
in my mind as a naive kid I thought man
if I could do that and get pretty good
at it to make enough money that I could
retire at like 35 or something
um and go live my life right like
have some other businesses you know then
then you're not too old to start a
family I knew this would be a rough
business to have a family and kids and
you know it doesn't really at that time
you're on the road a couple hundred days
a year it really didn't didn't connect
you know it wasn't as glamorous but then
was it not really but yeah yeah but but
it's a change business now people ask me
all the time about the business today
versus back then
I have three daughters 16 14 12 right
same but not the same age as well 17 15
and five which it's the best right like
and and
you know I've got one and I'm having
another sector yeah
I'm really looking forward to the
protecting I like when I go to sleep at
night it's something that I really like
sort of fantasize over I cannot wait to
have a sex with me I don't know how
anyway all due respect to both of you I
think you're both insane for having more
than one child yeah but I when when we
talk about the our industry there's you
know if you would ask me 25 years ago
you know hey you're going to have three
daughters how would you feel about them
getting in this business I would have
said hell no like not a chance I would
ever let them anywhere near it today I
would say absolutely if one of them
wanted to try to in what role were those
as a wrestler whatever role they wanted
to you know to me um I I my my middle
daughter is looking to play American
football and I've I sit on a a board for
concussion right so I understand the
dangers and
um I had said to my wife if we had a boy
I would never let him play football I
have a girl and she wants to play
football American football it's the only
girl on her team and I said yes and my
wife was like
how do you let her do it but you
wouldn't let a boy do it I said because
I don't want to tell her no as a girl I
don't want her to feel like well I'm a
girl so I can't do that yes she can try
to do anything
she wants to do I'm there to tell the
dangers I'm there to put there to
support her if she wants to do it and
I'm hoping girls are way smarter than
boys so I'm hoping that she's smart
enough to get hit a few times and go
like you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
do something different not for me do you
think being a girl dad has changed you
as a man
I think so yeah so look I think if you
go through life and you don't change if
you're the same person you were five
years ago you wasted five years you guys
and we'll get into the Attitude Era yeah
you've shown Michaels and you look wild
like [ __ ] it yeah and I remember seeing
an interview with yourself where when
you had started the DX Again by then now
you'd had a you was a dad and it's like
you can you certain things you've done
back then
it was it would be difficult to do as a
dad as a mature or a man
how do you feel about that sort of
change laughing at that point in time
too Sean had gone from born again
Christian degenerate to a born-again
Christian and there were moments in
times where we would do things like we'd
make suggestions to do things on TV and
try to make guys I'd be like well just
you cover your eyes so you have a
plausible deniability and I'll do it and
we would turn it into a joke that it was
you know it was funny that he couldn't
be a part of that anymore yeah look I
look back on some of those things and I
think to myself man I don't know how I
would feel about that today but same
point in time
I don't know I have this belief that uh
parents are there to be the parents not
TV not celebrities not all those things
they're going to be good good and bad
examples of everything in life all
around you and then it is parents jobs
to teach kids or or parents or guardians
or whoever that they look up to
hopefully that they have in their life
to say no that's that's not yeah that's
not real that's not reality that's not
what you want to do
my kids it's funny people sometimes talk
about what we do in the perception of
violence
um my kids have been watching this since
they were born right my first daughter
was on the road with us every day she
traveled on a bus with us and we come to
every show when she got old enough to
talk you know I I explained to her every
day what it was she would say uh she
would say to me before the matches like
we'd get to a show and she'd come in the
arena she'd say who's going to push you
down today dad you know because you know
what nobody should look at it who's
going to push you down right and then
she'd be backstage playing patty cake
with big show you know this man seven
foot 500 pound guy and then I would say
all right Mr me Mr Big Show gonna go
play now and she would come out and sit
in the crowd and watch us go perform and
you know but she inherently understood
it and not we taught him It's
Entertainment the whole way it's
entertainment it's amazing you've been
in the industry for three decades now
hard to believe that's an achievement in
itself I mean that's outrageous really
when you think about when you think
about the arduous nature of the industry
to be to be ever present for three
decades unreal is there a moment
or is there one thing that you're
particularly proud of if if it were to
boil down to sort of one thing is there
anything that stands out
it's so hard like
there's different meanings to different
things right so some people today will
joke because I have uh from a recruiting
and a developmental standpoint through
NXT
um I'm sort of nurturing these kids
careers in a way from the very get-go so
people will jokingly call me Papa H
right
um
but it truly is like there's things that
you're proud of in your career things
I'm proud of in my career that I love
that that you know were so meaningful to
me and I had worked so hard to get to
and all that stuff and and was so
meaningful but then there's moments in
time that really can only be
Associated to like saying
um you've accomplished things in your
life and you're very proud of them but
if you watch your kids accomplish
something that level of Pride that you
have is totally different and at a
totally different level so for some way
for me watching somebody that you know
Olton Randy Orton maybe or yeah or you
know a Charlotte Flair who came to me
one day and said I think I wanna I wanna
try this and I'm like surely you've been
around it your whole life but you have
had never had an interest why today and
you know we started from NXT yeah
homegrown you never stepped through the
ropes before you know until she got to
us and then hard to believe given her
family but but then to see where she is
now the level of stardom that she has
the level of success she's had how good
she is at this you know it's hard not to
look at her it's Rick's daughter but in
some way it's hard not to look at her
like one of your own kids and feel that
level of Pride for her so you know to
say one thing it's tough just
to me I just
I love this business I want to see it
continue into the future so in the
opportunity that I have now
um it's it's to run that creative and
take it into the future and that's a
massive responsibility but I'm humbled
by it and and really want nothing more
than to see it succeed because it's it's
it's everything I ever wanted to do so
to see somebody else that has that same
passion get that opportunity it's
there's nothing like especially as you
say you didn't or it wasn't that it
wasn't available to get that sort of
help at the time yeah
um the fact that you can as I say
nurture these it must it's a different
they call it in intrinsic reward where
it's like you're not getting paid it's
just a feeling I get paid yeah
yeah but there is a point that look
there's a moment just when we're
recruiting kids
where we're working with these high
school college athletes and you know
their dream right is to continue to be a
professional athlete their dream is to
get in WWE and they go through this
grueling three-day tryout and there's
this moment where we sit down with them
at a table and we're offering people
contracts to come start training with us
in Florida in Orlando Florida to see if
they can become a WWE Superstar
there's always stories to these kids and
sometimes you hear these stories where
like this kid grew up in a one room
Shaq with 10 kids with this has had this
you know Incredible Journey got a
scholarship was you know but eeked it
out through college has been starving
done all this thing and you say I want
you to come to Orlando Florida so to
train to become a WWE Superstar and they
break down and and lose it and it's
it's just 2013 people's lives you're
changing people's trajectory their
natural trajectory your your improving
them giving people an opportunity it's
crazy because I know what it was like
when I got that call yeah and I didn't
go through
a tenth of that you know like that
hardship and that level of of
um
you know difficulty in their life to get
to where they are and to have this
opportunity that if this pans out this
so it's it's not just like wow this
changes my life no this changes your
life your kid's life their kid's life
this is generational yeah
change for you
um you know and there's a lot of that
for us we we have a particular person
that I can think of that came out of the
military and just grew up in poverty
went to the military we found them in
the military they when they got out of
the military they came to train for us
and is now performing for us on a
regular basis and when I say like
like just
fully altered every person and every
person in their life it fully altered
their life nobody would associate it I
think when people think about the
industry I don't necessarily they think
that they think about what it gives back
right I think creating opportunity for
people and giving people a pathway into
a different life it's it's holistic as
much as it is entertainment isn't it
yeah it really is and then to see the
joy that they get out of then you know
uh giving back you know such a big part
of being a WWE Superstar is is giving
back in the community and stuff so
whether that's make a wish whether
that's
um you know supporting causes you know
pediatric cancer whatever that is their
ability to give back to you know when
you get to a place in your life where
you're a sick child's wish
there's there's nothing there's nothing
like all the money all the fame all the
other stuff is that big compared to that
moment yeah why do you think wrestling
has such a even if we make it more
specific to you why do you think DX was
so incredibly popular
I think in the moment we captured a Time
it's it's like at that period of time
Stone Cold Steve Austin right he
connected with people there was Vince
represented corporate greed and sort of
that 80s early 90s like
yeah corporate boss yeah that big phone
case yes
Stone Cold Steve Austin was the Everyman
drank beer right like I think so many
people in the world at that point in
time wanted to
you know who didn't want to go out
stun their boss drink beer over us yeah
drink beer over his life his body flip
him off run around make millions of
dollars and be the man right like it it
was perfect in that time frame we were
anti-authority on on every level of of
coming out of the sort of the the proper
70s and 80s and even like this like
cartoony 80s world of all of a sudden
real edgy like look that's who we were
we weren't doing we weren't going like
what would resonate with people today we
were just going out there and
entertaining ourselves in some way doing
what we thought was funny or
whatever was driving us to do we were
just being ourselves really Amplified
but it connected we were I think in some
manner speaking for what a lot of people
would have loved to done
um you know in their lives but it's in
real life you can't do those things
this is what I was just going to say so
the era of course that you you've talked
about there it's called The Attitude Era
rules right
um and I remember being I was about 13
14 around that time and a lot of the
teachers our parents you should say we
had attitude so when we saw
complimentary when we saw the guys like
representing attitude and all of that it
was like something for us to say like
not to go and be bad or whatever but it
was just it became really I was hooked I
was a way to Rebel yeah and and it's
that fantasy of it's a funny thing
we I say all the time like we were
everything we were the fantasy version
of every athlete in professional
Athletics so so guys would score a
touchdown and crotch drop the opposition
team and then they would get fined or
they would get in trouble by the league
or whatever it was they weren't allowed
to do that we were we were doing what
they wanted to do they wanted to go out
and spit water and do all the stuff I
was doing or you know to tell their
coach to suck it when they didn't like
the play calls or whatever right like
that rebellious nature there was so much
of that everything was so pent up and it
became
um I think it just became a sort of a
war cry in a way for a lot of a lot of
people in that generation who would you
credit like there's a lot of um
people that get credited for the
Attitude Era or was it a collective
thing it's a collective I think we were
all feeling it
um
you know it's a funny thing if you're a
corporate guy if you're Vince you're a
little bit older you're having to
appease corporate uh USA Network all
these different things that you have
above you you have to appease to some of
those things but he's a sort of a
Maverick and a rebel by Nature right
that's that's his thing the rest of us
were doing this business but we're like
sort of like this stuff isn't working
these cartoon characters and this
sort of following the rules is not
working like it it doesn't work for us
it's not what we would want to see if we
were just the fans this is not what we
would want to see so here's what we
would want to see when we first started
doing DX when when Vince first put us
together we hadn't even necessarily
called ourselves DX yet we were I mean
literally getting threatened to be fired
every week when we would come back the
events how is it Vince but he was
getting letters from USA there's a very
famous skit that we did where USA had
been honest for weeks these guys cannot
say that stuff they cannot do those
gestures they have to stop it we would
go out and do it the next weekend we
would come back and Vince would tear us
apart you guys are going to get us
thrown off the air god damn he was
pissed he wasn't
doing anything about it right like where
we felt like right it's like a lot of
things
going on but he's not really doing
anything and numbers are starting to
tick up a little bit right
so there's a moment in time where we get
this letter from USA Network that it
literally the whole letter is
DX has gone too far this Degeneration X
group has gone too far they're no longer
between the eight o'clock and the nine
o'clock hour they are no longer allowed
to use these words boom boom boom
they're no longer allowed to refer to
their genitals they're no longer like
it's written out and then from from uh I
don't remember the time from 10 to 11
they're no longer allowed to say these
things but they can use these words they
can do this they can't do that and Vince
brought us a letter and he's like well
here it is and and if these things
aren't met if these demands aren't
followed to a t they will you will no
longer be on the air in USA Network
right
they either they get fired or you're no
longer on the air and Vince like well
see you guys have crossed the line now
here it is black and white what are we
going to do about this and we said
let us take the letter and use it on TV
and he was like in what way I said we
will make that into a comedy routine and
we did up we did a did he agree today
yep and he was like all right
make sure it's funny
but he's got a pretty warped sense of
what's funny so it was all right but uh
we did like a presidential Podium and
the three of us got up there as if Sean
was president and we were standing
behind him and we went through the list
of words and they beeped the words we
weren't allowed to say and we said you
know this direct from USA we and we
indeed Generation X apologize for our
attitudes we will no longer say the
words and we went through the list and
then we will no longer refer to our
massive genitalia
we went through this whole thing and
then got into arguments about it goddamn
you can't say that well [ __ ] I didn't
know like right we would go so we turned
it into this comedy routine it was right
at the point when Bill Clinton had just
given the the I did not sleep with that
young intern and that's how we ended it
and Sean Michael said I did not sleep
with that young intern as a matter of
fact I was up all night
we did it as a skit
put it on the air did the rest of the
show
um next day we got a letter from USA
that said congratulations on the ratings
last night what DX did with our letter
was hilarious congratulations on the
success here's to many more years
it just shows you it just flipped and
and we sort of were of that mentality
going into those things of like look if
the numbers go up what are we doing
wrong
like in the whole point to get more
viewers if more viewers are coming in
like clearly we're doing something right
here that was early
um
so
you've spoken a lot about what you're
doing now and and what it is to be a
good performer where do you think you
did your best in ring work is there a
particular time period or a rivalry that
really sticks out for you try to say you
know sort of leading into that time
frame there's a moment in time where
the attitude errors in full swing and
then Austin gets injured and he goes
down with an injury and sort of it
becomes a rock and I which
the rocket is an interesting
thing because I come in a little bit
before he does
as a talent and I'm Hunter Hearst
Helmsley he comes in as Rocky my via we
wrestle over the Intercontinental title
he becomes the rock goes with the nation
of the nation of uh Abomination
domination I
transformed to Triple H like we're
coming out of these characters
transformed to Triple H DX has formed we
have rivalries of you know over that so
over the Intercontinental title then we
get into these groups and it's sort of
DX versus the nation he and I are
battling over the Intercontinental
Championship again then he
um you know full blown becomes the rock
leaves the nation I become Triple H
leave DX we battle over the WWE
Championship like our careers sort of in
a way
marry each other and are intertwined
with each other along the way and we
never sort of had that
defining
WrestleMania moment
um a few years ago we teased he and I
wrestling one more time and it was on
that he came to me and was like hey dude
I got one more in me I want to do it
with you I want you and I to have that
WrestleMania
sort of moment and let's do it at
WrestleMania and it turned out that uh
it was for the following year so we had
done this video for it and we're ready
to go with it and somewhere along the
time of that year uh his movie career
sort of changed and and he was like ah
man I'm not gonna be able to do this
timing just doesn't work out right and I
can't pass up this other opportunity no
problem
um but that's really where we were
headed but so our careers sort of up
until he left
for Hollywood and you know there was
this crazy moment and then or crazy
moments through all of it where it
mirrored each other during that period
of time when Austin left it really sort
of becomes in a lot of ways like you
still have taker you have Mick Foley you
have a lot of players but it becomes at
a high level about me and rock in a lot
of ways and then Austin returns it's why
we didn't in 2000 we had a WrestleMania
was like a fatal four-way or whatever
with a with a McMahon in each corner and
all that it was originally supposed to
be Rock and I and the Iron Man match
right that we did I think at backlash
they postponed that to backlash because
Austin wasn't ready to return yet and so
we sort of pushed the match out a month
which he and I fought hard against but
it was like you know it's better for
business overall if this and get past
WrestleMania to get to that but you know
that was sort of would have been the
culmination of I you know my rivalry
with him and him with me and it sort of
something we sort of missed out on but
God I wrestled Rock like
probably more than anybody maybe with
the exception of Austin because there
was a moment in time when when Sean got
injured I was the guy wrestling Austin
through all of that and then when he
would come back I would wrestle Austin
through all of that like
you know if you if you look at that time
frame of rock and Austin as being the
two biggest baby faces it's like you
know to give you like a Star Wars rep
it's like Han Solo and Luke Skywalker
who's the better good guy I was Darth
Vader yeah right and and sort of had
that role against the opposition of both
those guys it was a very cool period you
know what it's important to say as well
when Austin was up here and the
organization was up there so when he got
injured it was like oh no and then you
guys stepped to the place oh man I
remember the storyline as well when
Austin came back and the two-man Power
Trip which which at the time was it was
like a fantasy yeah man it was like
defensive because you guys dominate you
have all the belts and then you had the
great rivalry of uh the Brothers of
Destruction actually was that was in the
UK it felt accommodated wasn't it
Insurrection yes so like how did that we
were having a blast with it yeah and
then you know I got injured and then it
just changed the whole thing right and
it it totally took on a different
direction but yeah that was um
I don't know you know it's funny thing I
don't know Steve um
I don't think Steve ever really saw
himself fully as like a good guy right
he saw himself like he just he was like
me like I never was really comfortable
even in DX when we were popular I never
was super comfortable as a baby face I
always wanted to be the heel and sort of
that was my natural role I think he is
the same of that same mindset so there's
a moment in time where he was like yeah
what if what do you think if we uh you
and I did this thing where where man we
hooked up like it'd be unstoppable you
know and like
have you noticed in this conversation
quite how Starstruck our producer is
have you seen just that encyclopedic
knowledge of that you even know when
where the where the events took place
that's exceptional I remember
Insurrection at the time was a big deal
because it was in the UK and it was the
chance to see see the guys and I mean
yeah funny funny I'll give you a funny
story on that one okay I believe it's
that when uh tiger got his ear clipped
open by Steve's knee brace yeah and uh
we had to fly out for whatever reason I
I don't and again this is a little
sketchy from time but like
we had to get on a plane immediately
following the event like I remember I uh
we came in our gear and changed at the
airport we got on the charter and flew
back to the U.S and we were still in our
gear and we at the we got to the airport
and we went locker room and changed and
uh taker's ear was like hanging we had a
plastic surgeon gonna meet him in the
states and I stood for the longest time
on a seat behind him putting pressure
wow on his head in his ear because once
you get up at pressure right yeah like a
stuck pig
so I stood behind him for the longest
time holding pressure on his ear to try
to get it to stop bleeding while we were
flying home oh wow you're okay
it was his hair his ear was hanging on
him we named we named some um Legends
there Mick Foley The Rock yourself
Undertaker Stone cut like
if we're talking football terms that's
like the class of 92 right that was an
era was it was like an era defining
period yeah it's a funny thing though to
us like in the moment we you sort of
kind of knew how special it was because
you know you go back a few years prior
to that and and Austin and I are
standing at a curtain saying man you
think it'll ever get like it was in the
80s when Hogan and those guys were
running and everything was sold out and
then you fast forward six months or
whatever period of time that was and
everything sold out and Beyond we're
setting box office records everywhere we
go and and it's beyond that
in some manner you know that and in some
manner it's just Tuesday you know and
you're just doing your thing we've all
had that conversation I've I know I've
had it with Foley I've had it with
Austin I've had it with rock where like
man thank you for that time yeah yeah no
it's a nice way to look at it yeah you
didn't realize it how special it really
was and that it wouldn't last forever
like you know you always see that in
movies or something like this will be
the greatest time of your life and you
don't realize it and then you flash back
to that throughout your whole life like
that that moment in time that Attitude
Era where we went from yeah where the
guys you see on the WWE television too
you couldn't step out of your house or a
hotel room without getting mobbed with
everything wrong anyways in that period
of course were there any rivalries that
never came to fruition were there any
any uh opponents that you would like to
have cultivated more of a rivalry with I
mean I think there's periods of time
like so when Once once we win the war
and Monday night Wars and we sort of
take over WCW and guys come in
like I always wanted to work with Rey
Mysterio you know but I've I think I've
been in the ring with him like twice
yeah
yeah he's gonna be over here for clash
yeah but
um you know there's certain guys like
that that I I always would watch more
like uh such a fan of his work and like
just a a I could just feel what that
working with him would be like and how
easy that would be and how big we could
make it we just never ended up in the
same place in the same story lines you
know and I've thrown it out there a lot
over the years of like hey what if Ray
and I did something but he was always
like on Smackdown I was on raw or vice
versa and it just never panned out but
he was always a guy that I always
thought like man I would love to have
like you know gone and done something
big with him you've been involved with a
few errors that are like even as we say
that uh Evolution yeah uh Randy Orton
um Baptista
you're there again yeah and to go on 30
years and this is Jay-Z is my favorite
rapper not because of so much the lyrics
but the longevity yeah like being able
to okay the the scenes change now but
you move with it and that's what I think
personally like you think you know this
but that for me that's what you've been
incredible I I think sometimes of the
moments in the business that I was
fortunate enough to be but fortunate and
maybe sometimes unfortunate enough to be
a part of but like
um
you know I I sometimes I think of the
song Sympathy for the devils like the
devil talking about how he's been there
for these generations and all these
massive moments in history he's been
there for all these things like I look
at the curtain call right changes the
business I look at the Montreal scooja
like I'm I'm in the critical I'm
instrumental in the the Montreal screw
job positively or negatively
um you go to the Attitude Era at the at
the sort of the Forefront of that you go
to the Monday night Wars I'm the guy
driving the tank over to to WCW and and
sort of the Forrest Gump of professional
wrestling yeah
sorry I'm just going to stand behind
Sympathy for the Devil or Forrest Gump
yeah
I mean it is like a box of chocolates
but I feel way less cool now
um but yeah having those moments you
know Degeneration X Evolution you know
following that down the line
um even the McMahon Helmsley era right
the then then getting into the the sort
of corporate stuff of as a good area
yeah the the the authority
it's just being being so lucky and so
fortunate to be a part of all those
things but also to have such incredible
people to work with and to be a part of
those you know those moments with them
you know even even to when you come to
WrestleMania and like the the
uh Taker and I working in the end of an
era match with Sean in there and having
that moment where we're all standing and
in in some way symbolically at least for
us closing out an era that you know
sort of
took the business to a whole nother
level and sort of here's the three last
time like focal players of that time
frame closing it out all standing
together on that stage like it's it's
hard yeah it really is you know and and
even then like you talk about Evolution
like a moment in time of me saying like
God we need to build some new stars here
and I say well you know I go to Vince
and say well if you let me take Flair
he's like the Elder Statesman for us I
take it as my position and we give the
rub to new to a couple of new guys and
we form this group and let us take that
and and build two new Mega stars out of
this and he was like all right well you
pick you tell us who you want to do it
with and I'll tell you who I want you to
do it with and and we'll kind of get
back together on it and Rick and I went
and looked at everybody and we were like
Randy Orton Dave Batista they made a
different suggestion on one hand which
we then the cast aside but we Randy
Orton and Dave Batista and then we put
them with us and the whole goal of that
group was to get them both to be Mega
Stars eventually get to a place where
they go through me and Rick and they
become the next level people and you
know kind of worked yeah well is that
for you uh yeah well look that's part of
the storyline right but then then you
make them earn it but you know you look
at the the fabric of of that generation
after that there's
Dave becomes Dave Batista becomes one of
the biggest stars of that generation
goes on to make multiple talents goes on
to become guardians of the galaxies in a
massive movie star Randy Orton becomes
one of the best of all time and and
doing what he's doing and they had the
tools they just you know for me it was
about giving them the opportunity that I
didn't know if they were going to get or
not like Dave right prior to that was
like the Deacon Batista he was like
certainly wasn't lighting the world on
fire you know so those those are just
cool they're all cool moments to see
them all and go down you know can I ask
you what you feel with the influencer
the social media style YouTuber getting
involved with likes of boxing wrestling
with Logan Paul who you guys have signed
up right yeah how do you feel about it I
think it's great if you said to me hey
there's this guy Logan Paul he wants to
get involved in the wrestling business
wants to get involved in WWE he wants to
become a WWE Superstar and he comes in
and he's got an attitude and he doesn't
want to get hurt and he doesn't want to
take bumps and he doesn't want to do
what everybody else is doing and he
wants it to be special and all about him
I go again I'm not doing that
right
when somebody comes in that loves it
that is passionate about it that trains
their ass off for it you don't do what
he did
uh in in in the in the events that he's
worked for us you don't do what he's
done at WrestleMania without a lot of
hard work and a lot of effort same thing
with Bad Bunny this guy's the biggest he
just wins artist of the year the Video
Music Awards right he is in arguably the
biggest
musical attraction on the planet and he
is like hey when can I get in a ring for
you guys again yeah and when I tell you
that he was
like when he was going to do the stuff
for us
um with Miz and and all of that uh at
WrestleMania and and uh have that moment
was very honest with them like you're
gonna have to work really hard at this
went and got a house Orlando Florida
just down the road showed up every day
at that performance center got in that
ring every single day getting his ass
it's a story that people don't
acknowledge isn't it people often would
look at somebody like Logan Paul and
think oh I want that life but what they
don't hear is that he grafts he works as
hard as he possibly can as hard as you
can when I tell you dude that guy got
like he's not the biggest guy on the
planet right but he got beat up bad
every single day and he would show up
every single day I go to the performance
center a lot was my gig especially at
the time every time I'd be there they
beg bunnies in the other room train if
you want to go say hi like I had to go
in there he'd be killing himself sweat
pouring off him beat up you know yeah do
you is there you don't need to do that
is there a case where you say give it to
little bit extra let's put him through
no but you're not going to so there's a
fine line between what we do being very
real and being safe and right you can't
halfway do it you either do it or you
don't right you get slammed on the mat
it it hurts your guy jumps off top rope
lands on you it hurts there's no there's
no other way around it and you have to
learn how to do it because you have to
protect yourself and you have to protect
your opponent from Serious injury right
so you have to learn how to do it he put
in the effort if they're willing to put
in the effort and and and do that then
to me they're no different than me
absolutely they have a passion for doing
this let's let's let's go with that
passion for doing this Logan Paul let's
go with that passion for doing it let's
run with it and if he can make get more
eyeballs on us if he can make himself an
attraction if he can draw people in to
watch and they're excited about it it's
great for everybody you know and that's
the thing it doesn't have to be
everybody's First Love and rock wanted
to play in the NFL yeah didn't work out
for him yeah they end up doing okay for
himself right but it wasn't his first
thing that he wanted to do but but once
he got into doing it it was his family
and his family and he loved it but when
he started to do it he fell in love with
it even more and it became everything to
him
um you know he and I talk about that a
lot he'd go make all the movies in the
world there's no point in time when he's
making a movie where he stands in front
of a hundred thousand people with
Goosebumps all over his body because the
energy is just so unbelievable right
yeah you don't get that making a movie
absolutely nothing like it Triple H it
has been an honor to talk to you thank
you so much and Sport Bible stories just
one thing before because it's hot it's
like 95. it's really warm in here it's
really really warm yeah just one time so
we're gonna stop before I melt this is
an honor running order can I have a look
at your watch that is incredible that is
the nicest watch I've ever seen in my
entire life if you are listening to this
and you aren't on video this is just one
of the most beautiful pieces I have ever
seen lovely suit as well by the way I'm
just in all of you yeah I mean true or
you should see my underwear this is the
content you don't don't get to see on
Smackdown this is unbelievable top shelf
underwear thank you so much that is
thank you
[Applause]
people are you hard on mine up we didn't
win enough games right facts the eight
games that remaining were arguably the
best run of games on paper so that was
only about I couldn't get I was like
well that's the best run and you're
taking us out two days before the best
run well if you got a lap dance you'd
have to spin again so it's your fine to
get the number so when you do the laptop
genius